[Music]
that's Camila Kibeho shooting her
variety power of youth cover she's one
of three cover stars the reception
society that has been it's been so cool
to see especially because this song was
like eight months in the making and yeah
she's opening up about how seniorita
with rumoured boyfriend Shawn Mendes
came to be admitting there was a lot of
back and forth
finally we were just like you know what
no pressure let's just get in the studio
let's try to finalize it or let's see
how we feel about it and then two weeks
later we made the music video and was
that she also says quote I've known Sean
for such a long time and it's so much
fun getting to work and do things with
somebody who means a lot to you still
there's no confirmation the pair is
actually dating though a source recently
told et they are quote committed to
working on a relationship and there's
this video
[Music]
Camila is also opening up about playing
Cinderella in an upcoming reimagining of
the classic tale anybody that knows me
knows I'm obsessed with musicals you
obsessed with Disney I want to be a
Disney Princess like I read the script
and I was like I knew I like need to do
this the singer is also hard at work on
her next album I just feel really like
appreciative of being able to like live
and I feel like I just know what's
important in life right now so I'm just
I'm really happy and I feel very I don't
I feel like really in touch with my
emotions
[Music]